the world we live in today in terms of
autism was really created over the last
50 or 60 70 years from the time that the
diagnosis was first recognized which
goes back to 1943 and in those
intervening years families had to fight
so very hard to change the world to make
a place in it for their loved ones
because 5060 years ago the world didn't
want them people with autism were were
sent away to institutions they were
hidden they were not allowed into
schools they were discriminated against
they were isolated and the fact that we
live in a world now where things are so
different as a result of of very hard
battles fought by their families by
their parents in particular and the
reason that the past matters the reason
that we want to revive the stories of
what those parents did and those
families did over half a century is
because the job is really only half done
we're in a world now where there are
more people with an autism autism
diagnosis than ever before in a decade
five hundred thousand teenagers are
going to turn into adults with autism
and there really is no place for them
we've figured out what to do when people
are kids with autism we've made a lot of
adjustments in terms of giving them
education bringing programs into the
schools seeing kids and TV shows but
there's not very much set up for adults
there isn't a place for them to live
there aren't employment opportunities
and with so much left to do we think we
find in the past the inspiration for
what to do that activism works that it's
worth trying to battle it's worth trying
to change society's mind because
society's mind was changed in regard to
the kids but we really haven't come that
far in regard to adults and so looking
at the past
first of all just revives stories of
people whose stories deserve to be
revived
they've did so much to their stories are
on the son but they serve as an
inspiration for the job that has to be
done in the future particularly when it
comes to adults with autism we don't
know what the root cause of autism is
and there have been a lot a lot of ideas
put forth over the years people are
familiar now with some of them because
we lived through a period of time when
it was a very popularly held idea that
vaccines cause autism there are still
people who believe that firmly but the
scientific studies that have looked at
that have disputed that going back 50 or
60 years ago
it was the absolute gold standard
psychiatric opinion that autism was
caused by mothers not loving their
children enough that is what if if you
look at the text books on autism from
the 1960s if if a mother from the 1960s
took her child to a specialist she would
be told this is your fault you did this
there's something wrong with you and you
need to be the one who gets treatment
because you did something to your child
we have to figure out what's wrong with
you and there were there were women who
spent hundreds of hours and thousands of
dollars going through psychoanalysis to
try to figure out how they had hurt
their kids that sounds crazy the vaccine
theory has been disputed well that
leaves us still in a place where
actually we don't know still what the
root cause of autism is we don't even
know if there is such a thing as just
autism or many different autism's you
know autism is not doesn't have any
biological markers you can't do a cheek
swab for it or look at somebody's DNA
and say for sure you know oh that's a
case of that's a case of autism
inherited autism we don't have any of
that autism only comes down to everybody
having a general agreement about what
autism should be drawing up a list of
criteria looking at a person and saying
does that person's behavior match the
criteria or not well there's all kinds
of room for squishy squishy definition
in there there are people who are very
very successful professionals
particularly in the sciences you know
professors at universities who are
brilliant at math who nevertheless now
are labeled autistic because the
definition is so broad that it includes
them and and that goes to the fact that
they have strong real social deficits
they may have grown up being bullied and
teased for for being isolated and a
little bit different and not being able
to make eye contact and in the current
definition those people are now autistic
but so are the people who were autistic
under the label 50 years ago and those
are people who who have very very little
capacity for language capacity for
independence they're unable to dress
themselves if if the front door of their
house is left unlocked they will wander
into the street get run over by a car
they will if children will wander over
to the next house and drown in the
swimming pool that those kinds of
drownings are happening constantly
because that kind of autism is so so
very impairing and the I think of one
misunderstanding nowadays comes from the
fact that we have not really agreed on
what we mean by autism although we all
think we have right now autism is a is
an umbrella term for a list of behaviors
whose cause or possibly causes we don't
know